(anticipatory music)
- Hi, my name's Gordon
Bass, and I'm a writer,
and I want to tell you
a story about a man.
His name was Ben Carlin,
and he drove the oceans of the world
in an amphibious vehicle.
There was only one problem:
the vehicle tended to sink.
Ben Carlin met my grandfather in 1947,
so I grew up hearing stories about Ben.
Eventually, I became so
obsessed with his adventure
that I ended up writing a book about him.
Ben was born in Western Australia.
He was a smart kid, but he
could never shake the feeling
that he'd grown up on the
very edge of the world,
and so as soon as he was
able, he wanted to set off
and find adventure.
He'd started by mining for
gold in Western Australia,
didn't do very well at that.
He joined the Army and
signed up for bomb disposal
in World War II, but he
ended up repairing latrines
and runways, so he felt
he'd been a failure at that.
And finally, at the age
of 35, he decided he had
one more shot to accomplish something
that would put his name on the map.
He decided he was gonna circle the world
in an amphibious vehicle.
The vehicle in question
was an amphibious version
of the World War II Army Jeep.
So picture an Army Jeep
with a boat shell around it,
and that's what it was.
Ben found one for $901
and spent the next year
preparing it for his journey.
He called it the Half-Safe.
It was supposed to be good on
land and water, but in reality
it turned out not to be
so great on either one.
In 1948, Carlin and his
American wife Elinore
set off from Halifax, Nova Scotia.
The journey was not smooth.
The entire cabin was just 5 feet wide,
so the only way to sleep was to curl up
on the back bench seat.
The engine was so loud
that they just stopped
trying to talk to each other.
They hit a gale in the
middle of the Atlantic.
They thought they were gonna die,
and at that point they
realized they hadn't even
packed life jackets.
So by the time they got to England,
they had to completely
rebuild the Half-Safe.
They had less than $100 to their name.
So they ended up stopping for four years.
Elinore got a job, and
Ben spent a lot of time
preparing the next leg of the journey.
In 1955 Ben and Elinore set off.
They thought it would
take a year, at most,
and they would be able to
return to their normal lives,
have kids, and start a family.
When they hit the Middle
East and they were driving
through Syria and Iraq, Ben
discovered that he hadn't
ventilated the Jeep properly.
It rose to 170 degrees, and
they ended up driving by night
and then sleeping in the
shade of the Jeep by day,
so they could avoid the heat of the sun.
They were bandits, and
there were some roads
that they were crossing
that hadn't been traversed
by vehicles since the
middle of World War II,
which was 10 years earlier.
By Kolkata, the marriage was over.
Elinore had had enough, and she left.
Ben continued alone over sea and land
for the rest of the journey.
When he got to the States,
he'd hope for a movie deal
about his adventure, but
it never materialized.
In the end, on May 13th, 1958,
Ben completed the journey.
He traveled 40,000 miles over land
and 10,000 miles over water.
Part of the reason that Ben
never found lasting fame
was that there was no deeper
reason for the journey
other than to prove he could do it.
This was the era before GPS,
and before satellite radio,
and before distress beacons.
So Ben was really navigating
just by the stars,
and he taught himself how
to navigate out of a book
that he bought in a
second-hand book store.
What Ben accomplished,
going around the world
in an amphibious vehicle, it set a record
that stood for 60 years.
And not only has the
record stood for 60 years,
but nobody's even tried to replicate it,
which gives you a sense of the magnitude.